where is it that you really want to go
and the things that don't serve where
you want to go need to go away i think
those you know six hours or five hours i
sleep is more important than going to
six hours of meetings one of the reasons
my life has improved is because i've
shrunk the time frames down of where i
measure my results
wanna be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know you've got something more
inside you too you have michael jordan
level genius at something so today let's
live your best believe life and learn
the 10 habits of insanely productive
people enjoy
okay let's kick it off with habit number
one be around a players with robin
sharma choose your peer group really
really well there's a lot of excellent
science coming out and a lot of
excellent research coming out that says
the number one way to improve your
behavior is to surround yourself with a
peer group or social circle of people
who are also playing at the level you
want to be playing at so if you want to
be a high performer in terms of your
pride productivity
populate your life with high performers
now here's the science behind it in the
brain we have something called the
mirror neuron system of the brain and it
dates back to thousands of years ago
when we were living on the savannah and
this mirror neuron system allowed us to
model the behavior of the dominant
people in the tribe so if someone
figured out a tool or figured out fire
or a better way to survive
subconsciously this
system in the brain allowed us to model
the behavior and i think this is pretty
fascinating information
now here we are in the modern world and
what happens
subconsciously we are modeling the
behavior of the people we spend most of
our time with and so if you are around
victims you will start behaving like a
victim if you are around people who are
mediocre performers you will
subconsciously start behaving like them
if you around people who gossip who are
not a players who do not produce very
much you will subconsciously because if
the mirror neuron system in the brain
start performing like them
why else is it important to surround
yourself with a peer set or a social
orbit of a players
emotional contagion and that's a
scientific phenomenon that simply says
we pick up on the emotions of the people
that are around us and so if you are
around a social circle of people who are
inspired people who want to do great
work people who want to be ultra
productive people who want to be
innovative people who are relentlessly
optimizing their work their thinking
their creativity just being around them
will allow you to adopt their energy and
their ways of being habit number two
have a finisher list with brendan
burchard having my friday finisher list
what does that mean it means like you
know i've got a list here of the things
that have to happen
by friday it's my friday finisher list
it means that monday when i go to work i
am aware of all the things i need to get
done and complete by friday and that's
what i use at unit time called a week
four is making sure i get all these
things done by friday i know that by
friday
5 p.m or whatever time i want to finish
working on friday that these list of
deliverables have happened and they are
done and they are complete for the week
and if i can stay on track with that
oh my gosh
the the year just proceeds so much more
effectively rule number three study your
calendar with david meltzer nine months
out of law school i'm a millionaire
people ask me how did you do it wow and
it ties into the secrets of sales okay
right it ties in because i tell people
in your time frame
your time frame i work nine months in
mine
i work 10 years and like what are you
talking about i said because i look at
life through a lens of productivity and
accessibility how much value shifting
the paradigm of value how much value am
i providing
and how am i
accessing the help that i need as well
as being accessible to others to give
help very simple lens of of value and
because i believe people buy on emotion
for logical reasons and if you can have
the emotional attachment and value so if
i sold you something and guaranteed you
know whatever it would cost that you
would make double by the end of the year
you would do it everyone everyone would
do it it's all about value so i
literally looked at time that way and
said how productive and accessible am i
so i work six days a week
16 hours a day twice as much time i
focused in on efficiency so that was 32
hours of productivity if i was twice as
efficient then i looked at statistical
success of what i was doing if i could
be more statistically successful not
just because i was a young sales guy so
if i have 10 leads
people think that you're more successful
if you sell four and i sell two i
disagree if i have 10 leads and i can
make more of those 10 leads available to
me yep i can be a worse of a sales rep
because usually what happens is somebody
that can close four out of ten with that
skill set only has six people available
to them they're wasting all their time
on the four trying to get on the phone
trying to get the meeting trying to get
all this
so i focused on availability because
it's more productive so if i could get
all 10 available
i could be way worse sales rep and close
5 out of 10 right at 50 instead of at 80
so i really focused in on that so i work
seven days a week 16 hours a day my
perspective though just so you know
mindset
i told god i'm graduating law school
with no job law loans in a recession
before i got offered those jobs i said
god if you can give me enough money to
buy my mom a house buy my mom a car and
pay off my law loans i will shovel [ __ ]
with my hands six days a week 12 hours a
day with gratitude that's where my
mindset was so when i got a real job a
six-figure job with opportunities to
make seven figures there's no stopping
me in productivity accessibility do the
math you know if i if i have 64 hours of
productivity a day right the 16 times
two times two is 64 hours of
productivity a day times seven days a
week
where do you get the 64. so so most
people work eight hours of productivity
yeah i work twice as many hours so
that's 16. yep i'm twice as efficient
that's 32 hours of productivity
and then twice as statistical and then
twice as statistically successful i
would have 64 hours of productivity a
day and then twice as statistically
successful
to the availability
yeah yeah like close focusing on the
money closing or the amount of sales
yeah awesome being very very focused on
the money i believe profit comes first
not passion and purpose i think people
are fooling themselves when they're like
i want to do what i love i'm like yeah
[ __ ] learn to love what you do yeah
people say become an expert at what you
do yeah and you'll love it but pursue it
and i did it with productivity and
accessibility full dedication yeah and
so in nine months i i believe i had ten
the average sales guy was married with
kids wasn't motivated and inspired like
i was wasn't pursuing what i was
pursuing so in that nine-month period i
produced ten years of what the average
person would produce i love that
therefore i had a million dollars
yep right which is you know basically a
hundred grand a year for an average
person
but i was able to do it through time
effort productivity accessibility i'm a
student in my calendar which means i
study my calendar with the lens of
productivity and accessibility i study i
study sleep so smart because my
subconscious fourth of your life or one
third from some people not me one fifth
for me but yeah literally i s because i
study sleep i'm more productive and
accessible in the subconscious and
unconscious than anyone i know because i
think those you know six hours or five
hours i sleep is more important than
going to six hours of meetings like for
my literally productivity accessibility
i also study the white space in my
calendar so more people forget their
most important calls and meetings during
the day because they just look at their
calendar yeah and i've done it i'm an
expert at this stuff i've forgotten
meetings i forgot important calls ones
that i've waited three weeks for i'm
like how'd the day go by i forgot to
call yeah because i started studying my
calendar the other secret is do it now
think about productivity and
accessibility if you learn to ask
yourself one question hey can i do this
now
and you do it you save at minimum twice
as much time and your statistically way
more successful than if you put it
somewhere else now one other tool is if
i can't do it now i have a do it now
repository either on my phone or in my
outlook yep so in the white space in my
calendar when i don't have something
planned i go check my do it now folder
prioritize it by importance and i knock
them off one at a time rule number four
take a break with marie forleo unlike
computers which are built to work at
high speeds running multiple programs at
once over long periods of time we humans
are not designed to work that way in
fact best-selling author tony schwartz
says this
a growing body of research suggests that
we're most productive when we move
between periods of high focus and
intermittent rest
that's why it is so important kelly to
intentionally take smart effective
breaks i've created an acronym called
reset r-e-s-e-t
you ready let's do this
step number one r stands for review your
day and plan breaks in advance now
ideally you're gonna plan your work day
including your break times the night
before now if you haven't seen my video
about why planning your day the night
before is so damn important you need to
watch that right after this one but
here's what you need to know according
to research if you decide in advance
where and when you're going to take a
specific action you can double or triple
your chances of meeting your goal now
you might be asking how many breaks
should you take and when here's a good
rule of thumb take a 5 to 15 minute
break every 90 minutes of dedicated
focus time step number two stands for e
meaning make it easy to remember so in
other words make taking breaks a no
freaking brainer put them in your
calendar set up notifications or set
timers on your phone because if you're
anything like me once you put your head
down and you get into that focus zone
you can be in the cave for hours without
ever looking up to like i don't know eat
or shower or pee personally i've
forgotten to do all of those things
step number three s stands for step away
from the screen so meaning during your
breaks no email no social media or web
surfing so put down your phone and close
the damn computer why you might ask well
a study done by researchers at the
university of illinois and george mason
found that
reading websites and checking email
taxes many of the same mental processes
that we use when we're working which
actually makes fatigue worse so what
should you do instead move on to step
number four which is
step four
exercise meaning you need to exercise
and hydrate now i want to talk about
hydration first because dehydration is
debilitating studies at yukon's human
performance laboratory showed that
dehydration can negatively affect
concentration reaction time memory mood
and can cause headaches fatigue and
anxiety so drink a big tall glass of
water then do something to move your
body get outside in nature take a walk
around the block do some stretches or
heck one of my favorites take a dance
break finally step number five t stands
for tune back in so once you've walked
or stretched or danced take a few deep
breaths and tune back into the project
you were doing or the next project on
your list remember where attention goes
energy flows and what you want to do is
redirect your cognitive energy back into
focus mode
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there rule number five have daily
targets with grant cardone you gotta
have daily targets
every day i walk in with a target i have
a planner and basically what the planner
does is the planner starts off two
sheets of paper
it's got it's got it looks like this
it's a notebook right and this is this
is the right side we start on the right
side this is gulls
at the top
and this is targets
okay first thing i'm gonna do is i'm
gonna write down these ridiculous
targets oh i'm gonna get a i'm gonna get
a helicopter okay i'm gonna get a brand
new helicopter eight passenger i got it
in my head i got it mocked up it's black
it's got a 10x underneath it dude it's
got choppers i'm not doing that this
year 10 billion dollars worth of real
estate all this ridiculous stuff goes
here 10 billion worth of real estate
daily targets you need a daily target
what has to happen today what what
that i can measure today
uh in order to stay focused on my goals
tomorrow next week and next month if i
can't pull today off
if i can't pull today off you know in in
when you're recovering from drug
addiction it's one day at a time
handle today
i used to go to a meeting three times a
day three times a day every day seven
o'clock in the morning one at noon one
at eight o'clock people say luna that's
a lot of that's a lot of meetings man 21
meetings in one week
but yeah you know what i don't wanna i
don't wanna fall off man i gotta stay
focused i'm weak the devil's got me rule
number six have a timeline with dean
graziosi how do leaders go to another
level
is
they know how to replace being busy
with being productive let's just say
like it is we want to be more successful
you wouldn't be here you want to be
happier you want to have more time more
freedom more control right
so if we want those things we got to
make other adjustments leaders
know how to be beyond not just busy but
be productive because we're all busy
none i don't think there's any of you
watching me right now saying i just got
five hours a day i don't know what to do
myself dean but i guess the question is
are the things you're working on
actually moving the needle in your life
or just keeping you busy because we can
get on the
treadmill of life and always be running
never get anywhere like it's almost like
being on a treadmill and it's on number
seven
and you need to get downtown so instead
of getting off the treadmill and being
productive and moving you just put the
treadmill up to nine you're going faster
faster faster but you're still
running in place
so how many of us have
felt like we're
running in place right so i want you to
think in
absolutes like
no gray area okay so let me give you
some examples of
binary thinking
you're either climbing
or you're sliding no hovering no it's
okay no in between climbing or sliding
there's only two activities things that
move the needle in your life and things
that don't move the needle there's
activity that either drains you
or energizes you it's either a yes or a
no it's either victory or death burn the
boats so what does that mean it's like
so we're i'm obviously setting you up
for something to really make hardcore
decisions because here's one thing we
all have we all have 24 hours in a day
like how does one person seem to get so
much done did they invent the time
machine and they actually got 36 hours
in a day
or do they know how to say no
do they know how to look through a lens
of black and white it either moves the
needle
in my life it takes me towards a bigger
future more income more happiness more
joy better health better connection
better intimacy or it moves me away from
a better version of me
more money more happiness and it's i
don't want to oversimplify it but when
you start looking through the lens of
binary thinking it's either yes or no
you have to be brutally honest with
yourself overwhelm's a part of a bigger
problem overwhelm has symptoms such as
lack of clear-cut objectives which
really means clarity
when people tell me they are too busy i
just say you're not clear
what does that mean you don't know how
to say no to the things that don't serve
you god your bigger future your family
your friends your money
your happiness your joy you're saying
yes to too many things you're in like a
hypnotic rhythm of things you used to do
but the things that you used to you used
to do got you to where you were but you
want to go to another level so you have
to say no to the things you used to do
so you can go someplace else and that
requires clarity
so where is it that you really want to
go and the things that don't serve where
you want to go need to go away
black or white
not an easy thing this is how you get
there deadlines right you say i'm going
to tap into that course i'm going to
read that course i'm going to start that
new business when i'm going to get to it
doesn't work i'm going to i'm going to
finally start focusing on the marketing
and sales of my business because it's
been neglected when i'm going to get to
it no that ain't never going to work you
need a deadline and a time frame and you
need to schedule it with targeted
deadlines like like like the world is
going to collapse if you don't get it
done because
it really is you're going to just go
right back to where you were right
doesn't mean your life is horrific but
if you want to stay where you are then
keep doing what you're currently doing
or make deadlines rule number seven
block time with lisa nichols what i did
overview really fast overview as
i took blocks of time
from 6 am when i woke up
to
11 p.m when i went to bed
i took blocks of time some 90-minute
blocks some 30-minute blocks some
two-hour blocks no matter what i needed
to do
i added
to 30 minutes to it if i thought i could
get it done in an hour i gave myself 90
minutes to do it so you're not
going from one thing to the next and one
thing to the next thinking that a time
management system is really making you
stay chop chop it's not it's not
designed to make you stay chop chop in
an aggressive
intense stress producing way it's
designed to keep you on path for the
things that you say are important to you
so the first thing i realized the first
myth that i changed was giving space
inside of my day given space inside of
my time management
so i add 15 to 30 minutes to everything
for example
i wanted to check my email for um an
hour no i'm sorry 45 minutes every
morning so i put in 90 minutes i just
doubled it and i was never in it for 90
minutes so after the email after i
checked the email i had a moment to go
do i want to go downstairs and get
another thing of orange juice do i want
to do something else and so
padding time supports you so i block the
my entire day from wake up to go to bed
i add 15 to 30 minutes to each task then
i block it out to the most key tasks so
the first thing you want to do is make a
list of the things you do
almost every day
so that's
for me it was have breakfast and make
breakfast for jilani it was get ready
for the day these are my major tasks it
was take jelani to school get jelani
dressed for school take jilani to school
it was check my email
it was
return phone calls it was make sales
calls
it was picked jelania from school it was
do gelani's homework with him it was
cook dinner for jelani and i it was get
jelani ready for bed it was my prayer
time it was show and graded for bet
myself it was you notice you see this
was 2006 and i still remember all the
major pillars of my day i may have
forgotten a couple out there like in my
morning i do my gratitude time but i
knew my 12 my 15 major pillars of my day
and i took those major pillars and i
dropped them inside these 30 minute
blocks
hour blocks are two hour blocks from the
time i wake up to the time i go to bed
my 30-minute blocks were primarily free
time
so i dropped in
three or four spaces where it just said
breathe
you would not believe what happened now
i didn't do the same thing every day but
most of the days i was up to the same
thing and i had some general buckets
called ceo time that gave me time to do
whatever i need to do for the business
and then there was a bucket called
home time i could do anything for home
so i had open space time allocated to
either home or personal or
business now whenever that schedule got
disrupted
whenever i got back to the schedule i
just dropped in to the structure already
set what did it do for me it allowed me
not to have to figure out what to do
next it allowed me focus i didn't roam
around so much figuring out i didn't
spend dollar time on penny tasks
i checked my email twice a day at 9 00
a.m and at 3 p.m and that was enough i
did two hours of sales two days a week
what did that do that grew my business
at the time i was making 72 000 a year
in 2006 when i started the very next
year after doing two hours a day two
days a week of sales i was up to 185
000. that's so that's pretty good it's
well worth the time management
and so all of a sudden there's structure
but inside the structure there's some
fluidness there's space to breathe rule
number eight use a calendar with jaco
willink i always say this when people
have trouble with tasks put them on the
calendar
you know actually jamie does that for me
when jamie's got something for me to do
she just doesn't email me and say hey
you need to do this she puts it on the
calendar so i look at my calendar boom
there it is i gotta go do this whatever
this task is done
so put these things on your calendar and
that includes
scheduling time on your calendar so that
you can have time to
consolidate your list and do a review of
your lists you know whether that takes
that probably take 15 minutes to do
and
i guess there's a bunch of apps you can
use and i'm sure people will make
recommendations but there's a ton of
to-do list apps including there's one
there's native ones on all the different
phones so you could look at that as
possible rule number nine measure
performance with ed milette there needs
to be an alarm clock where performance
is measured performance improves
secondarily the more you can shrink the
time frame where you measure performance
the better chance you can have to alter
that performance and improve it so what
do most people do they measure their
performance the average people in the
world measure their performance at the
end of every year
new year's eve right they take an
account but here's my life
here's what i accomplished here's what i
didn't get done and once a year they
take a look at themselves they make an
adjustment and their performance
improves
they measure their performance they
measure the results and then they make
an adjustment so they adjust about once
a year pretty good performers shrink the
time frame at the end of every month
most companies kind of do an inventory
most people do an inventory they look at
their books they look at the profit and
loss
they look at their schedule and they
make an adjustment after they measure
that performance at the end of the month
really good people kind of get together
on a sunday night
if they're pretty good performers once a
week they measure their performance they
make adjustments and they move on weekly
and then there's really top-level
performers and they do at the end of
every day don't they the end of every
day they sit back they look at their
calendar they look at the results and
they measure the performance daily well
who do you think is going to do better
the person who measures it once a year
once a month once a week or once a day
we all know the better adjustments they
shrunk the time frames down they adjust
they get better they improve daily and
then there's the max out one percent of
one percent performers
and they have a clock that goes off
every hour
every hour in their head the alarm goes
off in my mind it's sort of weird but it
works
i'm addicted to it now about every hour
the top of every hour at 11 a.m it's
funny my mind just knows what did i do
to move closer to my goals what did i do
to move closer to my outcomes if i
achieved the things on my to-do list
today have i achieved my biggest and
baddest outcomes of the day and every
hour did i move closer should i move
closer what adjustments do i need to
make what do i need to celebrate what
tweaks what's been accomplished so far
an hourly alarm clock goes off in your
head if you can get to the point where
you just begin to practice it and maybe
for now
you program this thing to go off every
hour just to remind you what did you get
accomplished maybe when that hour goes
off you know what flash is on the screen
your outcomes and your goals hourly the
alarm goes off hourly the alarm goes off
it'll begin to train you to begin to
measure the time frame of your
performance every hour now let me ask
you a question there's a group of people
that measure their performance their
race their marathon is once a year then
there's those that do it once a month
and make adjustments and measure where
they are and increase effort then those
that do it monthly weekly daily
hourly i can tell you that i run many
days and i measure for my performance
hourly it will transform your life you
will become more productive in your
family in your personal relationships in
your faith in your business in your
fitness in your nutrition
in your money in every area if just
something goes off every by the way it's
a five second just reminder am i move
closer to my outcome if i move closer to
my to-do list today what adjustments do
i need to make you'll be reminded at
that time of someone you forgot to call
an email you didn't return a meeting you
haven't asked for yet but something
you're supposed to eat hydrate whatever
it is if you can begin to have that
alarm just go it's just five seconds
it's just every hour it's just five
seconds and i'll tell you it happens to
me constantly now and i know that one of
the reasons my life has improved is
because i've shrunk the time frames down
of where i measure my results
right where i recalibrate where i course
correct where i make an adjustment where
i realize i'm behind or i've made a
mistake and i improve a performance and
so so far can you imagine if you started
just being a bigger hurry
and you had perception correct about how
close you really are to your goal the
difference in winning and losing is this
much it's like a veil and when you
remove that veil you see my gosh i'm so
much closer i promise you one of the
things that you suffer from isn't just
like a lack of vision and clarity i wish
you more clarity and more specificity in
your vision and i wish you more
proximity that you knew how much closer
you were to achievement than you think
you are in fact it's the fact that you
think you're so far away from achieving
these things that's causing them to
constantly stay that far away from you
because you're not running fast enough
towards them you're not measuring them
fast enough but you're killing your
goals and your dreams by thinking
they're so far away it kills everything
if you knew how close you really were
you'd run so much faster so if you
altered that if you altered the first 30
minutes to an hour of your day and you
just stopped letting yourself be a
reactor but you took control and became
a dictator of your time if you
manipulated and bended time like i have
to where a day is six hours let the rest
of the world think a day is 24 hours by
the way someone just made that crap up a
long time ago an hour of measurement 24
hours is a day 365 is a year someone
just made that up and everybody's bought
into it well guess what i've made mine
up my days are six hours long i've just
manipulated and changed time it's a
figment of our imagination is how time
works and what if an alarm could go off
every hour in that mind of yours in that
heart of yours just checking just a wake
up call just to wake up just an alarm
hey am i closer to my goals am i closer
to my outcome what adjustments do i make
what course corrections what was
achieved what am i grateful for it's
just a five to ten second reminder and
you're back off to the races again if
the earth spins around once we call that
a day
if the moon goes around us once we call
that a month
if we go around the sun once we call
that a year it's just stuff people made
up right and so time is a figment of our
imagination and if you'd use your
imagination
imagine what you could accomplish if you
shrunk the time frames down and rule
number 10 the last one before some very
special bonus clips is increase
attraction with j shetty we spend over
47 of our time when we're browsing the
internet or on our mobile phones
procrastinating and we check our phones
around 86 times per day put your hand up
if you check it more than that
so it's no surprise that we all face
distraction we all experience
distraction we're all plagued by
distraction but often we think that the
opposite of distraction is focus we
think that we need to become more
focused we think that if we're focused
we'll feel less distracted we feel that
if we're able to draw our energy in a
certain direction and force ourselves to
absorb in an activity then we won't be
as distracted but this is just not true
the opposite of distraction is actually
not focus the opposite of distraction is
wait for it attraction let me explain
what i mean when we're attracted to
something we're completely fixated we're
completely absorbed we're almost
addicted and obsessed to that visual
that song think of a time when you saw
someone that you found attractive i'm
guessing you couldn't take your eyes off
them think of a time when you heard a
song and you had it on repeat all
throughout the day no matter if there
was drilling outdoors there was a
building being demolished nothing could
distract you from the sound of that
voice and that beat i know you can hear
it in your head right now
[Music]
what we really need to do is increase
our attraction when we are attracted to
something we're naturally focused we're
naturally able to be present we're
naturally able to bring our attention
and our energy to that task that project
that person when we're distracted and
don't have that attraction we're
naturally all over the place we end up
feeling lost confused and end up
procrastinating as you can see we are
procrastinating and distracting others
so now i know what you're thinking how
do you get attracted to things that
you're not attracted to we all have
things in life that we love to do and we
all have things in life that we have to
do i'm sure you have a long list of
things that you have to do and you're
thinking jay i'm not attracted to any of
those things whether it's doing your
accounts whether it's taking the trash
out maybe it's even your job
it is my job so i've got a tip for you a
little trick a little insight that will
make your mind understand and believe
that it's attracted to something let's
take the example of your job it's
something that you have to do it's
something that you may not be attracted
to when you ask yourself why do i go to
my job maybe the answer is it pays my
bills maybe the answer is it allows me
to take care of my family maybe you
studied for years and feel that your job
at least engages you for that whichever
one your answer is that starts providing
some value to why you do that activity
when you know that you recognize that
you are attracted to be there because it
serves a particular purpose you start
becoming attracted because whenever your
mind says to you i'm bored i'm
distracted i'm unfocused you say no i'm
here because it puts food on the table
i'm here because it pays my bills and
takes care of my family i'm here because
i studied and worked hard for this
you're able to increase your attraction
to even the things you're totally
unfocused on
having a big wine a little why so big
why is why do you do what you do what's
the mission what's the vision you have
what's driving you i want to solve the
world's biggest problem i want to wake
up every day and try to help a billion
people
right it's never gonna happen it's the
the big dream that will never happen but
it should be motivating right what is
your big why if it's just money you're
never gonna win money needs to be in
your top five just not number one so
what is your number one what is your big
why without that it's really hard
every entrepreneur that i profile the
ones who've made it big you're heroes
they have a mission they have a why what
is your why
that's the big why the little y
is on a day-to-day basis because
sometimes the big y is too big sometimes
that big y is motivating and it's
amazing i can't wait to do that but
sometimes the big why is too big it's
like ah i don't think i can do that i
mean that goal is never going to happen
why even bother why even try it's too
far away
i mean i'm not going to be able to do it
and it actually is so big that it
deflates you that can happen
so the little why is well i may not be
able to
solve the world's biggest problem but i
know i help the people who love to
comment on my video i know i help the
people who left me an email and so
remembering that the work that you do is
important matters
waking up every day and knowing that the
work that you're doing today
matters is meaningful serves people
somehow right humans are built to serve
it's my new book if you haven't
pre-ordered it yet it's in the
description go pre-order it's amazing
you're gonna love it right humans are
built to serve and so knowing that the
work you're doing is of service
reminding yourself whether it's having a
powerpoint file or having letters on the
wall or whatever it is to know that what
i do matters i may not be anywhere close
to hitting my big why but i know that if
i stop doing what i'm doing today
at least one person is going to be
disappointed at least one person is
gonna lose out because of work that i am
not making right that's your little why
remind yourself daily that the work that
you do matters
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want 10 insanely productive morning
routines check out the video right there
next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there why do i focus on gratitude first
thing in the morning well i have my
vision board and then my goals
everything that i want but i also have a
gratitude board the things that i'm most
grateful for in my life and if you want
to feel instant gratitude just